Welcome to our talk um hope you're
having a good conference so far um this
talk is about event driven data science
um so it's a bit of a um a meta talk
about how how you do data science um
so uh This Is Us uh um I'm Patrick deil
I'm a Distributive systems engineer
machine learning specialist it's kind of
a long job title but I'm also a python
go programmer and I
also enjoy rock climbing I'm joined by
my cooworker primar Roman um she is also
distribut systems engineer um EML Ops
specialist and she does teaching at
Georgetown University and enjoys walking
around DC um so she'll be showing a bit
of a more practical demo um later on the
in the talk but first I want to start
with the question of um how like why is
so hard to get models into production um
so I'll start with this quote which is
87% of data science projects never
actually make it into production and I
think there's a few ways to actually
interpret that um one is that um it is
uh kind of hard for data scientists to
deploy models into
production um another uh explanation
might be that most Day science projects
actually just um fail
um so there are a few things to think
about as we go through um rest of this
um talk here but I want to start with
something I call the kaggle effect which
is if you know about kegle it's a um uh
resource and Community for data sets and
um collaboration data scientists and I
think what it shows is that um data
scientists are really good at working
with data sets that are nice and bounded
and they don't have any realtime
components to them and you can train a
model which works as you expect it to
because you have this kind of bounded um
data set um and there're no really uh
surprises once you've uh um deal with
all the um the outliers and stuff
so um if you think about what you do um
as it is scientists um traditionally and
this batch um data science flow um is
that you start by injesting a lot of
data and then wrangling it and getting
into the format that um you want and
eventually you'll build models and maybe
have some nice visuals
um uh but the problem here um is that
it's basically completely um neglecting
the idea of mlops like how do you get
these models deployed into production
because if it's not in production then
these bottels are not going to be very
useful or at all um so what happens is
that batch machine learning um you have
to have a batch of data to train a model
and then once you have more data you
have to grade an even larger batch um
which increases the time that it takes
to train your model
um so it's also increasing the time it
takes for you to iterate and try new
things um even though the more data is
supposed to um uh lead to better
performance for your model uh and the
fact is that um once you train the model
it's Frozen um to that at that point of
time so that um you won't be able to
actually change um any aspects of that
model and I can't really react to like
real time things that are going on with
like users on your
system um giving you feedback stuff like
that um so let's return to the question
uh why is it hard to deploy well um one
reason is you might not have enough data
that you can sufficiently represent U
reality and what's going on in the real
world um uh so your models might just
not work um out of the box and and uh
you might your models might um be
outdated by the time they get deployed
because um you know things in the real
world change very quickly and your
models will not be able to keep Pace
with the changing data because they were
trained at a certain assumptions um in
the past and iteration is really uh for
deploying the new new models is really
expensive um mostly because um as data
scientists we're not really trained um
how to to do um mlops um and so if
you're a data scientist you really want
to be focusing on the M you want to be
focusing on doing the data science and
that's really the fun part and ml Ops is
mostly not the fun part so um I think
sometimes we uh data science struggle to
uh to like adapt to that um situation
where you need to be deploying new
models um so here we're going to
introduce uh this concept of
asynchronous um data science um uh which
you know in contrast to this batch way
of doing things um the batch batch way
is uh completely linear so you have to
do ingestion before um you do data
wrangling and data analysis and also
every time you get new data you have to
repeat those steps over um again um
which can take a long time um depend
depending on how big your data set
actually is and you can also run into
memory issues um uh if you're just
trying to train things locally or even
in the cloud
so um but in async data science you are
reorganizing your your um data into
streams right so you no longer have
these giant batches of data instead we
we have is like
streams and you can think of them as
like Topics in pubsub right so you're
you're publishing and subscribing to
data streams and this means that all
your processes going to happen
concurrently right because um you don't
need to wait um for everything because
uh all this is happening
asynchronously um so if we look at an
example here um let's say I have a uh um
a recommendations app called Kel I guess
that's for uh restaurant recommendations
for vegetarians I suppose um and I have
this app right where I I can give
reviews and uh I can give
recommendations to users and they give
back re reviews and ratings into the
system so my goal is to try to train
like a model um that can actually give
good recommendations for users um but
the problem is like this state is
changing over time right because users
taste will change over time as they
discover new things so um what I really
want to do is I want to have this kind
of asynchronous inferencing engine on
the right here
um uh uh which uh will allow me to
actually um get those models updated and
actually personalize um some of the
models for the users but um how you
actually integrate those things is I
think not very clear um
traditionally um so one solution is to
just make everything um asynchronous
with data streams so what this means is
that um you have your you have various
uh topics um where you have you know
your Ry data and your clean data and
every and your process data and uh what
this allows you to do is um if you have
data streams
uh you can just publish um And subscribe
to those streams and all these boxes
kind of represent your different um
processes whether it be like your
different Jupiter notebooks or your
microservices uh like you might have a
service where you it just focus on
deploying models you might have a
service which is just showing the
visualizations for um how the models are
doing and you might have your actual
application where you're using the
models um uh in production um so this
way kind of requires you to kind of
rethink how you're structuring your data
um in your organization into like these
data streams instead of these um these
like data uh like lakes or like these
data Big Data um um sources in your uh
in your
organization so we talk about uh
realtime machine learning like how does
that actually work like how do you um um
do this with the async data streams well
you really these models are kind of
designed to learn one at a time or one
kind of mini batch at a time um so this
means like the training cycle it never
ends like you never reach a point where
like okay I'm done with this B I'm never
going to train it um again um instead
your model is continuously learning um
as new data comes in so this is based on
the assumption that you will have to
update your model um every time uh new
data comes in so it does make it less
susceptible to drift model drift in
those cases and uh kind of follows the
inverse Paradigm of the batch uh model
which is like um now you're predicting
and then you're fitting um so it's also
referred to online or incremental
learning so I might hear that from uh
other
places so uh if we compare batchwise
versus real time or online learning um
in uh batchwise modeling uh there are a
lots of tools which uh are kind of
designed for this and I think that's why
most people um tend to start with
batchwise um machine learning because
it's easy to understand and it's uh
really good for certain use cases like
if you have to process like an entire
network or compare different parts of
your data set um but you know there's
this lag time between retrieving between
the time that you received you data and
when you can actually update um those
models
so in contrast the real time machine
learning is you um it make does make it
easier to deploy new models uh um
because you have those data flow set up
um and you're um uh and it takes a lot
less time to train the models because
you're only learning one at a
time
and
uh but um one downside might be that um
a lot of Eventing tools um out there
like Kafka aren't really geared towards
data scientists um per se they're more
geared towards kind of like classical uh
computer
um scientists or Engineers um who are
dealing with microservices um so that
might require you to kind of shift your
mindset into more of a functional
programming um uh
State uh but uh realtime models are
really best suited for um things like
anomal detection and uh you know Rags uh
where you want to have those
personalized models uh for users and
um uh various other things so they're
actually real real use cases for um
these online
models um so at this point I uh will
pass it over to Prima so uh we can
actually get into some um code and some
uh demo we can
[Music]
show for some more practical things
all right hello everyone uh so uh I'll
go ahead and share my screen for the
remainder of the
presentation um so um thank you Patrick
and so as you've um seen so far you know
Patrick went over uh realtime learning
and asynchronous data science and you
know how you kind of combining the two
would help you not only build but deploy
your models a lot faster than
traditional batchwise um machine
learning models and so I'm going to kind
of talk to you about you know how you
can Implement um an online learning
application so even before kind of
getting into the weeds of the code
itself you you want to kind of first be
thinking about like at a high level you
know what your use
cases and uh you know think about the
you know how the data will flow into uh
the application um so you kind of think
about about like all the different you
know data sources that you're going to
be ingesting from and how um the data
Transformations will occur at each step
of the process and at a high level you
want to think about the topics uh and so
topics are like tables in a relational
database you know it's a way to organize
your data but unlike relational
databases uh topics in a um in a
real-time system um you know allow you
to act on data as soon as it appears um
you know in the table like you know
versus uh your traditional relational
database where you might you um extract
data at some sort of an interval and
then um along those lines you want to
think about the event handlers which are
which are going to be the components of
your application that interact with
these topics so there are kind of three
different flavors so you have your
Publishers that will write data to a
topic then you have subscribers that
read data from a topic and then you have
handlers that are sort of a combination
of publish ERS and subscribers and so
what handlers do you for example you can
have like a a component that reads data
from a topic does its data
transformation has some results and then
publishes these results to another
topic and so here we want to introduce
you to enen which is a streaming data
platform specifically designed for data
scientists and so the idea here is that
you have a topic let's say we call it my
topic and you have a publisher on the
left that publishes what we call an
event into this topic which is just a
piece of you know data related to your
application and as data scientists you
have two ways to interact with this
topic you can either as we're going to
show you now how you know in a real-time
fashion where as soon as new data Ares
in this topic you can you can make
inferences you can learn on this data
immediately or you know you can also uh
query for historical data and you know
there are definitely applications you
know where you can just take you know
read in all the data that's in this
topic and use it for uh analytics and
other use cases so it's very flexible
for both you know batchwise and and
streaming
operations and so here let's actually
take a look at a specific use case so
imagine your restaurant owner and um a
lot you know your customers you you want
to make sure that your customers are
happy with the experience that your
restaurant and so a use case would be
where you can ingest data from yel
because often times like you know it's a
very popular you know platform for
people to publish uh reviews and so you
have a publisher that injest data from
from Yelp and then uh takes that data
and publishes it in a topic called
review and then you have a subscriber on
the other end that as soon as new data
arrives at this review topic um it will
uh subscribe to this um data and then
initially do an infant so you know we
talked about online learning where you
have the it's a predict fit uh Paradigm
so it'll first make the inference and
then it'll then use a label to learn
from uh from that um record and then now
you have an in you have an inference and
you have the label um you can use it to
compute metrics and then the subscriber
can then publish this metric to a
metrics topic and then you can have
another subscriber on the other end that
as soon as it sees the metric it will
compare to a pre-defined threshold and
send an alert If a metric you know Falls
below that threshold so now here you
have an opport to do not only you know
building a model and learning from the
model but you also have a way to Monitor
and do all of that in real
time and so now let's get to the uh the
demo portion so the code um is available
here um and essentially there's three
main comp um three main components of
this application you have uh a Yelp data
publisher that will do the publishing of
the data and then you have a subscriber
on the end that will run the inferences
and learn from the application and
publish metrics to um a metrics topic
and then you have a metric subscriber
that will then read the metric and see
if this metric you know is uh if it
falls you know below threshold it will
um it will print out an um a message
saying that the metric is uh below um
you know below the
threshold and so uh I kind of have this
set up here so these three components so
we'll first run the the metric
subscriber and then we'll run the Yelp
data subscriber and then last we'll run
the Yelp data publisher so you can see
that of in real time like as soon as
data appears you know you have you know
in the first section you can see the the
data and here you can see the Precision
and recall metrics um for each record
and then you can see here you know in
the cases like where the the scores were
below the threshold uh you can see that
this uh is printed out but then imagine
like how in real time you can you know
um have this you know kind of
notification set up so that you can
react
immediately and so kind of uh going back
to uh the talk um you know we invite you
to um uh try out real time models and
you have two ways uh to do this uh so
the first is you can try out the nen
sandbox and it is you know it's free to
use and we have um um if you uh click on
the n and U link you have a lot of
resources that you can use to kind of
help you get started and there are a lot
of examples that you can play with and
use the uh Pon SDK so it's a python
Library just you know like you use
uh um you know for um interacting uh
with enen and then the other option is
that we are offering um you know five
Pro consultations and you just have to
bring your data source and you know we
have years of experience building
building machine learning models and
deploying them and so we can help you
build your application and if you're
interested um you you send us an email
and this uh offer ends this coming
Monday so you can send me an email if
you're interested um
and and then we'll help you out and uh
I'll Now open up the floor for
questions
let's see it looks like there are a few
in the Q&A so if you want to navigate
over
there so first one is how would you
validate that a model update actually
improves the model
performance um so there's probably a few
ways to to do this because um you know
as I mention like you have the Precision
and recall so we had the Precision and
recall scores so if you kind of want to
see see like for each record like did
the score actually improve you can uh
you you can hold the um the previous
precision and recall metric and if you
want you can compare the current um
Precision recall or any other metric
that you're looking at and actually the
one thing that I didn't mention was that
you know when you actually run that
particular example like you know you saw
those alerts coming in and initially
like as you'd expect you know when the
model's First Learning on this data the
scores are not going to be that great
but then you'll see that as the model
continues to learn and you know gets
more instances that actually adapts and
um and over time those scores actually
improved but you know as at each at each
level you see the uh the scores and so
you can see what the latest scores and
kind of compare it to you know the
previous
scores awesome um another question is
how can we solve the latency problems
example for an iot
scenario
all right Patrick would you like to take
this
one sure I can take this one um uh it's
a great question
uh I think uh the interesting thing
about um data streams and um in online
learning is that
[Music]
um uh you know I think the latency is
actually probably going to be less than
if you're doing the batch wise um
modeling because um as long as you're
publishing as soon as you get the
signals from your iot um then you should
be
able um to be as up to dat as um
possible so I do think that um the
Legacy problems are kind of alleviated
by the kind of data streaming um
methodology but
I uh do also see um situations where um
uh you might be uh still having to deal
with that latency so that was a good
question um and then same individual who
asked that last question where is the
checkout
list
um actually don't know
what that refers to
all right Ali if you could specify back
in the Q&A that would be awesome but
we'll move on um so what does eign offer
compared to other streaming
Frameworks um so uh so it's a good
question so um anden like there's
there's definitely a lot of options that
you have for um for data streaming and
Eventing um um what uh ensen is um like
one difference is that um as well as uh
realtime data you also get access to all
the historical data that you've
published to any topic so um that
happens by default so in other uh um
systems um they are um they might be
more stateless or by default so that you
don't get to view the historical data
and run queries on it
um you would need some other tools to
kind of uh help you with that and also
um what we really wanted to do is design
the API in a way that's very python
friendly and very um developer friendly
um so as you saw like earlier in the in
the slides like publish And subscribe
should be like on liners and you should
only need to know what data stream that
or topic that you're connecting to um so
ease of use um and persistence would be
kind of the two um main differentiators
that uh we were kind of um building
for all right um so going back to the
where is a checklist so it says you have
it on your slides um example what real
time models are best suited for this
slide has a checkout list but there is
not a link mentioned can you give us the
link okay
so there is a slide earlier I don't know
if you PR you can go to
that or you mentioned like you link to
like yeah that's what one
slide more
there's a link to
uh was it
h yeah
do let's
see yeah there
so I'm wonder if I can get that um post
a link oh there
okay let's see if we can post this I can
probably post this
here there you
go
awesome we got that um is this a local
pub sub async solution orders or does it
work in a cloud distributed environment
Etc or example rather Azure
Services
um yeah great uh great question uh so
what the solution the um answer is is a
managed service so um and we're
basically Cloud um Native so it's just
kubernetes so we could deplay um
anywhere we uh want to um but what
you're doing what you're really doing um
when you're doing the publish And
subscribe is that you are connecting um
to the to our broker to our managed
broker um in uh that we're hosting so
you don't the big advantage of that is
that you don't have to host anything um
you just have to have an API key um
that's
it
awesome so with the last 120 seconds or
two minutes any other burning questions
please put them into Q&A oh there we go
can we have selfhosted
Brokers that is also a very good
question um so all the code is open
source so if you want to you could um
build it yourself and run your own
broker um that's how you would do it
right now
and I just yeah want to add that one of
the advantages you know of using nen is
you know it's kind of specifically for
you know data scientists like there's a
lot of work that you you have to do like
just in terms of building a a model and
um and you know working to like deploy
the model and then having to think about
devops is like you know having to like
add another skill set and we kind of the
the advantage that Enon offers is that
because we are a managed server like you
don't have to worry about allocating
CPUs or memory and thinking about all
those kinds of things and that's
something that we handle and so this
kind of helps you kind of focus on kind
of what what you do best which is to
build machine learning
models and then one last quick question
before time expires um does is this or
supported for Julia
language so it's a great question um
we'd certainly like to um develop more
sdks in the future uh currently we
support um python primarily and also go
um so those are the two um sdks that are
uh available right
now awesome and that will bring us to a
close Patrick and Prima thank you
greatly for this awesome presentation
and thank everyone for hopping on and
taking some time out of your day to
attend um obviously we can continue this
conversation in Discord there will be a
recording if you want to play it back or
share it with any of your network um but
I'm going to end the session so everyone
can get to their next um again thank you
everyone for attending and I look
forward to seeing you in this session
very
shortly